these are roller skates this is robots
this is a series of music videos
featuring some of my favorite artists
grooving on wheels oh and this is an
iconic scene starting bow-wow also
called Roll Bounce and this is me trying
to learn how to roll bounce in a week
[Music]
grown at the Kansas City it was really
common for black teens to go to a
skating rink as a way to make friends
and build community a lot of times I
didn't feel like I fit in but skating
was a way for me to feel like I belong
somewhere I'm gonna get someone to come
in teach you the basics of Roll Bounce
teach me a routine and then I'm gonna
perform it here at the office in front
of everyone and hopefully I don't get up
like any millennial trying to find a new
skill I took to social media to find an
expert I came across the local skate
crew called skaters with attitude or
swa4 short and remember this guy for the
migos video that's quest - gate coach my
name is quest I'm the CEO of SWA row
bounce to me is when you're skating you
know you bouncing with it you're filling
yourself and use Road skating at the
same time so it's all the movement
skating rink is always open for anybody
to come skate and have fun in my end up
liking it and falling in love when it
keeps people out of trouble it brings
together a family you know bond with the
people that you see every week me comes
to the rink so it's all about family
when you come to the skating rink I can
skate in the sense that I know how to
not fall I'm excited to anybody minute
like I like teaching I love skating I
got a passion for it like if I go
skating I love my friends I don't feel
uncomfortable I don't feel like I'm
gonna die you put they got the time you
got the hours you can be better than you
think but I don't know how to like dance
on skates
I have some rhythm depending on the
hours we put in anything as possible and
I don't doubt nothing roller skates have
been around since the late 18th century
John Jessup Maryland is a first person
known to have been to the roller skate
and designs were typically more aligned
with inline skates or rollerblades we
can excel Pompton for the four wheeled
roller skates that we often see today in
1863 Plimpton patented the 2x2 roller
skates senior roller rinks around the
country after adding leather straps and
metal side braces in 1866 Clinton
founded the New York roller skating
Association and created the first public
roller rink in Newport Rhode Island
Quest's tried to teach me the crazy leg
and I was not good at it
[Music]
well it is day two I found out last
night that I am not that good of a
skater I'm not a bad skater but I'm not
as good as I thought I was we're going
to keep practicing that crazy like we're
gonna do this I want to learn we're
gonna get done this is it this is what
we're gonna be in a couple of days I am
gonna perform a skate thing here this is
gonna be a lot harder than I thought but
I'm excited to be working with the crew
it's cool to be doing something that is
so directly connected to my roots my mom
is a skater I hope I do her justice how
am i doing we got this quest that's good
okay better than yesterday that's all I
can ask for it's better than yeah it's
cool to work with diamond in quest it's
getting to a point where it is just
feeling very good question I was a lot
of like good advice and he's just given
like great tips on like things to
translate into life also just cool to
get to build like build a community in a
different way lots of improvements yeah
Qwest honest opinions we doing good
together
the chemistry used to click I'll sit and
talk to them in a quest they're going to
a skate party in Atlanta and they talked
about how so many different stages go
out there and you really get to see the
community you build with skating and you
get to meet a lot of cool people and a
lot of different types of people and
there's just so much love there it has
been a really cool experience so far the
performance is gonna be fun this week
has been a lot we're gonna get through
it this was hard we added a new ending
finale so uh we're ready
hopefully tomorrow but uh we'll see I'm
gonna have a tane love split that I
can't get so it is
the night before the big performance I
am exhausted it's just so cool to see
adults Kate because it's so much more
layered and there's so much more of a
culture in the history in skating that I
didn't even know existed it's been a
really cool week getting a no diamond
inquest cuz it's just like we are
starting to make our own little inside
jokes and we're starting to just kind of
laugh hang out with each other and like
I don't know that I've become the best
skater or anything like that but I
definitely do feel like I've kind of
started to build this community and I
think that's what the most important
thing is I'm excited to kind of feel
connected to black people in a way that
I didn't necessarily knew I would feel
some Rosberg performance I need to get
to bed cuz I don't know how I'm gonna
pull this off today is the final
performance I am very very nervous I am
supposed to split today I get to split
one every three times but I'm gonna
practice a little bit before question
time and get here and we're gonna do
this we're gonna nail it we're gonna
crush it so we are going to perform in
like 30 minutes do I need anything else
before I go out there you need a mindset
say focus on getting there right and
this shirt right here
Oh official swag here skaters with
attitude honorary member here yeah
wobble it's probably cuz I fall all the
time so like it fits me this is a
perfect skate I'm ready I'm ready to go
out and kill it yes
[Applause]
going into this I was like oh this is
gonna be a piece of cake it ended up
being a lot of work but it's better that
way I think it feels better because I
had to work for it
this really helped me connect to like my
childhood and made me think about like
when I was younger and I felt like I
don't know it was like quote-unquote
black enough or whatever and like it's
just cool to like be in a community of
like people doing something super cool
and artistic
the performance went well just like we
practice these four days the energy was
good and everything's on point and a
half I'm doing it I definitely want to
keep skating I miss it I used to do a
lot when I was younger and now that I'm
here doing it again I've got the bug
again it's so much fun the crowd was
great at this up
[Applause]
we needed that split I thought he was
trying to finish somebody's man he's
amazing I love him so much he did so
great and that splits like oh my god
this is an incredible experience
and I'm just excited I just want to let
go roll around again so I'm gonna go
okay bye
[Music]
hey guys do you know it's Anna character
from Loyola people content right here
[Music]